hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast dissecting the ecological
and molecular mechanisms underlying the
interaction between plant viruses and
their insect vectors presented by dr.
Puna no Chapa associate professor
department of biology for June
University we are excited to bring you
this educational webcast
presented by lab roots the leading
scientific social networking website and
provider of our treatments and webinars
advancing scientific collaboration and
learning i'm julie simmer a live lab
reads and I'll be your moderator for
today's event before we begin I would
like to remind everyone that this event
is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
from the green internet' button located
in the lower left of the presentation
window then type your question into the
box that appears on the screen we'll
answer as many questions as we have time
for at the end of the presentation also
please notice that you will be viewing
the presentation in the slide window to
enlarge the window just click on the
screen icon located on the lower right
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation please click on the
support button at the top right of the
presentation window or use the Q&A
button to let us know that you're having
a problem this is an educational webinar
and this offers free continuing
education credits after the webinar is
over please click on the ze button
located in the bottom right hand corner
of your webpage and follow the process
of obtaining your credits please join me
in welcoming dr. Pina Nakata I will now
turn the presentation over to her hello
everybody today I'm going to be talking
about my research which focuses on
understanding psychological and
molecular interaction between plant
viruses and your insect lectures and
down here on the slide you can see some
of the viruses that I work with that
I'll be talking about during my
presentation
so plant pathogens are transmitted from
plant to plant in two main routes there
is plant mediated which it came into
mechanical contact between plants there
is vegetative propagation via cuttings
grafting a plant a plant the packages
can also be seed transmitted pollen
transmitted and also this very unique a
mechanism via a parasitic plant called
daughter that can transmit through its
vines the pathogen of the virus from one
plant to another you also have something
called vector mediated now the stem
might be new to many of you but a vector
is an animal or an organism that
transmits the pathogen from one infected
host to a healthy host a very common
example is mosquito that transmits
Plasmodium which is the pathogen that
causes malaria disease from one human
from the infected human to a healthy
human but my research is focused on
plant pathogens which is what we'll talk
about today the majority of pathogenic
bacteria and fungi do not require an a
vector you know an animal to transmit it
from one plant to another but most plant
viruses do in fact need vectors or
organisms to transmit them from one host
to another and these vectors include
insects mites fungi and nematodes among
these various vectors insects occupy
predominantly the largest group
comprising about 64 percentage of all
the known vectors that transmit plant
viruses now plant virus and the vector
they interact very closely the other
viruses within the insect and oftentimes
it's multi-plate multiplying and
replicating within the insect or through
within the plant and this can lead to a
myriad and several different
interactions between the virus the
insect and the host plants
so you can have dialect effects that is
when the virus seen here affects the
insect vector in this case is an aphid
directly due to the presence of these
virus inside the aphid and these effects
can be positive negative or even neutral
when there is no effect at all and I say
positive effect I mean the virus
increases the vector a reproduction rate
or develop or shortens the development
time sometimes it can even come for
protection against predators and
parasitoids so those are what I say
positive effects and negative effects
would be something where the vector
Fitness is reduced now the virus can
also affect the vector indirectly so let
me get rid of my pointer here indirectly
via the plant so the virus can multiply
within the plant as we as I've already
told you about and then due to the speed
and due to changes in the plant
metabolism that can then indirectly
affect the insect vector and again you
can have positive negative and neutral
effects similar to the direct effects
there could be changes in reproduction
development time longevity and even
changes in behavior so needless to say
this is a very complex interaction and
not one the sort of mechanism switch all
the different insect vector systems so
the central questions that I study in my
lab at Indiana University Purdue
University in Fort Wayne is to
understand how plant viruses affect
biology and ecology of their insect
vectors and what plant and insect
mediated responses or mechanism underlie
this complex interaction to do that I
use an integrative approach by looking
at the ecological outcomes at the
organismal scale and
processes at the server in a small level
so basically using both plant assays and
insect assays as well as molecular tools
and you'll see throughout my talk
examples of this approach so as I said
each system plant virus vector system is
unique and I study two systems one is
tomato spotted wilt virus in western
planet chips which are actually studied
in the past but during my postdoctoral
research associate experience at Kansas
State University and currently I study
soybean vein necrosis virus and soybean
trips interaction but what's common to
both of them is they both these virus
viruses belong to the genus tosco virus
and the insect as the last name denotes
our trips you can see this term here now
what's interesting is there is no
singular trip both singular and plural
is trips
there's no trips it's if you will so
toss the virus is probably the most
important plant virus that affects a
wide range of crop plants throughout the
world over thousand cups which is you
know a huge range for a plant virus
currently there are around 20 identified
possible viruses and 15 flip species
that are known to transmit them what's
important to understand here is that
toss providers are exclusively
transmitted by clips no other insect can
transmit the virus and trips
predominantly transmitted just this
genus nataas for what is the cause over
a billion dollar in Angelo specifically
this one tomato spotted wilt virus so
understanding the virus vector
introduction is crucial for management
to develop management strategies share
some pictures showing some of the
symptoms of tomato spotted wilt virus on
tomato you can see these
actually there you have concentric
circle did you pay closer attention
this is impatience necrotic spot
Wireless which is in peppers and this is
soybean necrosis virus as you can see
the typical necrosis or the dyeing of
the tissue along the veins and hence the
name soybean vein necrosis virus I'm
sorry I think I mean a error here and
this is impatient yes impatience
necrotic spot why this and then this one
right here is iris yellow spot virus now
as I said all cos Pro viruses are
transmitted by trips and the more of
transmission is what we call persistent
propagated what I mean by that is the
virus replicates within the insect
tissues and is then transmitted once
it's acquired it was just illustrated
here in this diagram so a trips would
would acquire the very arms while
feeding on the host on an infected host
plant as you can see the vidiians
passing here through the mouth bats the
esophagus it then moves on an infix the
fold out of the insect and from there on
to the mid cut which has three sections
and trips may cut one Mitka two and
matka three runs is too much infection
in the meta three predominantly inmate
got one from there the viruses then
trance move past the mid cut epithelial
to these tubular salivary glands you can
see these tubes that connect the mid cut
to the principal salivary glands up here
and there also structures called
efferent ducts that also connect the mid
cuts to the salivary glands the vidiians
move through there and infect the
salivary glands and then when the when
the insect feeds on a healthy plant and
they salivate the vidiians are
transmitted to the healthy plant
so the
is called persistent propagated a manner
of transmission so another interesting
feature about this and though the
specificity of the interaction between
the virus and the trips vector is
illustrated by the fact that it's the
larval stages and when I say larvae I
mean in matures in this case or the
babies or offsprings so to speak it's
the first instar or the very first
larvae that emerges acquisition of the
virus at that stage is crucial and that
stage lasts for two hours the next stage
which is the second instead you can see
here they can also acquire it but to a
lesser extent so acquisition decreases
as the larvae ages the pupil stages are
- and they do not feed thereby they
don't acquire the white virus and then
the virus is passed on Transkei dearly
from one stage to another and the other
clips you can see the female here and
here's the male which is smaller both of
them can transmit however adults can
only transmit if they required the virus
in the first instar larvae or second
instar larvae stages adults cannot or
they can acquire but they will not be
able to transmit the virus so then the
question arises how is that that only
adults have acquired the virus in the
first instar stage can transmit it and
there's some evidence that in the larval
Anatomy the answer lies in la mulana
anatomy of these tips in the sense that
during the first instar stages the
salivary glands you can see here good to
get this arrow the salamy glands are in
close contact with the mid gut the
anterior part of the mid-cut that I
talked to you guys about which is
right where we saw most of the infection
so this allows the variance to pass
through very easily just by direct
contact this may be the reason why first
instar larvae that acquire the virus can
transmit it as the dollars so looking at
the specific virus vector system let's
talk about tomato spotted wilt virus and
trip Specter as I said pathogen is at
hospital virus and tough the viruses are
in the family boondi every day although
I do I believe there's been an update
every simply in it extended infects
twistin 900 mm plant species worldwide
there insect vectors are several
subspecies that can transmit from into
spotted wilt virus but frankly Nala
occidentalis which is Western flower
trips insect here that you see is the
main vector now it looks pretty large in
this figure but they're not really
adults
measure two millimeters which is known
longer than your eye a single eyelash so
working with these insects is a
challenge and these are symptoms of
tomatoes but it went viral on peanut you
can see the beautiful concentric circles
here and this is why it gets his name
spotted but of course it doesn't only
affect tomato I've already talked about
this in the introduction so I'm not
going to go over it again so I was
interested to understand what effects or
waterfix
so meters per adult virus has on its
inside vector on 20 another occidentalis
what we found was that while is
infection of the host block tomato
include insect fecundity or reproduction
in other words insects Western flower
trips that fennel tomato spotted wilt
virus infected plants had higher
fecundity as you can see here infected
trips feeding on infected plants had
higher fecundity almost twice in three
Sacre triplicates one two and three
compared to those that fed on uninfected
plants so in some manner this virus
infection in the host plant improves the
plant quality and this is what we refer
to as a positive indirect effect the one
I was talking to you guys about in the
first couple of slides now we were
further interest on Stan what is the
mechanism that's improving the plant
quality you know so that it benefits the
vector to do that to do that be used
micro arrays so micro array is nothing
but a gene chip essentially a chip that
is spotted on with these different genes
or cdnas of tomato which were species of
plant or animal you are working with
people interested but tomato change
ginger so we used this from a company
called Affymetrix
it is right not on micro arrays that are
slightly outdated technology people
usually go in for RNA sequence equal of
total transcriptome whereas on the chip
you are restricted to whatever
oligonucleotides or jeans or cDNA is
that is spotted or that's present on
your gene chip nevertheless the tomato
gem chip had close to 10,000 a little
more than 10,000 gene which is a lot
which is a significant number so we had
three different treatments and these are
both keno plot showing the number of
genes that that we considered was
significantly different with respect to
the mock inoculated or control treatment
so let me go back so I can explain this
jumped ahead too much
okay so this is an actual one of my
actual microchips that had those 10,000
our genes spotted on them and this and
each pixel or spot that you see on this
volcano box plot is a gene that was on
this chip so we had two levels of but
affiliation for change on two levels of
significance for change and also the
p-value so anything that essentially in
it any spots that's in red and what we
considered significantly different
compared to our control treatment so in
with respect to tomatoes per adult virus
treatment we had a total of three
hundred and seven genes that were
differentially expressed compared to the
mock treatment in which we just
mechanically inoculated the plant
without the virus just simulating the
same level of damage so on the right
hand side on this side the genes are
upregulated or positively expresses you
can see here with the full change and on
the left hand side are ones that are
negatively expressed or they're down
regulated but in either case both sets
of genes the ones in red are above the P
level of 0.05 which is the base level
that we set it at okay so trips
significantly expressed a total of 171
gene which is almost half the number of
the virus infected genes and this is
understandable because when a virus
infects a plant every cell it's systemic
every cell is infected whereas thrips
feeding is very local and the
combination of virus and thrips had the
most number of genes 424 it's almost an
additive effect
and this is not surprising because you
have two different attackers the buyers
and the insect which means the plant
will have to activate a lot more twice
the number of genes to combat it we was
specifically interested in defense
pathway genes specifically two pathways
the salicylic acid pathway and this
pathway is predominantly expressed in
response to the pathogen and just monic
acid pathway which is up regulated in
response to insect of trips feeding what
we found was that virus infection up
regulated you can see all the positive
numbers the up regulated size Lily gets
it pathway I'm only showing you a subset
of three genes here but we had close to
20 to 25 genes and there was an
concomitant reduction in just monic acid
pathway genes which means virus infected
plants down regulate the pathway that
the plants used to defend themselves
against insects and including trips
which means the plants are more
susceptible to trips infection and they
are you know could they don't have their
defense mechanism on insects will find
them more readily attackable because
they don't have to turn on a you know
defend themselves against these plants
you know defensive pathway so trips
feeding down regulated as you can see
and the salicylic acid pathway which is
understandable they don't turn on the
sub skating doesn't cause a plan to turn
on a pathogen regulated party whereas
this just want to guess it pathway was
in fact turned on but interestingly in
plants that had both virus and threats
you did not see down regulation in
either of the pathways which suggest
that the plants are able to manipulate
or modulate their defense
such that both salicylic acid and just
monic acid pathway can be upregulated
not to the same level as they did when
they were they had a single attacker you
can see the levels here slightly lower
but still the plant is able to defend
against both attackers but what's key to
understand is that in wireless infected
plants here salicylic acid pathways are
regulated but just Monica's a pathway or
the insect related but it's down
regulated making the plant more suitable
or more susceptible to insect attack and
that's what we saw maybe one of the
reasons why why does infected plants
were more preferred for trips and that's
why the earth ecology increased if you
remember on the slide that I showed you
the other aspect of plant metabolism is
nutrients and nutrition can also
increase insects become de t so we
analyzed three total free amino acid
contents in plants there is no change in
amino acid content between uninfected
plants and trips trip plant they are the
same level but in plants that were
infected with tomato spotted wilt virus
or the combination treatment you saw a
significant difference compared to
uninfected a trip sloth which means that
virus infected plants have higher co2
free amino acid content which must have
also made up might have also contributed
to improving vector fecundity so
summarize this part of my research and
we found that a tomato spotted wilt
virus had a positive indirect effect on
the insect vector trips by improving
fecundity we also saw our analyzed
host preference which I didn't talk
about today we believe that two main
factors may have contributed to
this positive effect one was the
defensive crosstalk that is a regulation
of salicylic acid pathway and down
regulation of just monic acid pathway
and the insect related pathway which
allows the plant insects too readily
feed on the plant and not have to deal
with the clan defenses and increase an
amino acid content which is critical for
insect development and these amino acids
were in increased in the virus infected
plant to uninfected
in terms of the direct effect it's
largely neutral tomato spotted wilt
virus doesn't seem to impact have a
positive or a negative impact on mr.
flower trips Fitness so switching on to
the current system that I study another
toss Pro virus which is soybean vein
necrosis virus as we envy you can see
some pictures here with the I should say
symptoms you know the symptoms and it's
interesting because unlike to me just
put it this valley which is very system
again it infects all the cells as sv
envy is very localized within a plant if
you were to test a plant this section of
the plant tissue and we were to obtain
positive for s VNV and what it is this
portion where you don't see much of the
lesions this one would be negative so
within the same plant it same leaf in
fact the virus doesn't seem to be moving
as well or is not a system it compared
to tomatoes but in birth mothers it's a
newly identified soybean trust provirus
identified in 2008 in Arkansas and
Tennessee in 2012 soybean trips was
confirmed as the vector and you can see
the adult insect here this is the first
instar the one that is more efficient in
acquiring the virus and this is the
second instar given that it's a new a
newly described this
these there's not much information on
the disease and the insect lecture
although the insect vector is found
almost all soybean fields that we've
sample so it's predominant but not of
major consequence until recently so this
is the spread of SVM V currently and
when I say currently we haven't had
other more States reporting it but it's
possible that they are in other soybean
growing regions of the Midwest Dakota
North Dakota and Nebraska but very
quickly within a matter of five years
the disease spread to most of the major
soybean growing areas and now it's even
founded Ontario Canada so as I mentioned
briefly the survey soybean fields using
what we call a suction trap this is what
this these traps look like and they
sample the air and collect threats we
found up to eight different species not
including including sorry including so
it means it's just not in this list
right here so there's a lot of
subspecies in soybean fields and these
suction traps are distributed throughout
the Midwest we saw through the ones in
Indiana so the the point that I'm
alluding to is that that there are other
tip species some of which are known to
transmit our other toss devices that
could also transmit soybean vein
necrosis so what we also found in this
in this system is that SP Emily
infection include thrips fecundity not
to the same extent as tomato spotted
built- but there was like a 15 20
percent increase in the conditi or
reproduction of SP and the infected
individuals
compared to the uninfected individuals
however when we analyzed the log copy
the virus copy numbers in each of these
females
and if you look at the relationship
between SV NV and fecundity you see a
strong negative correlation so higher
the so you can see this the negative
current very clearly so basically the
higher the viral viral copy number or
very on the name set the lower the
fecundity so to some extent it seems
that the virus is beneficial but as the
virus level gets higher it seems to have
a negative effect on the fecundity now
other I should mention that other life
history traits we did a look at will not
different it was only the country that
was different we also looked at host
preference order feeding behavior I know
it's it's a little busy and I should
have had one of them come in this graph
come in a little later but to just focus
on this one right now which is host
preference of infected soybean trips
which is the so called the vector right
the ones that are infected are the ones
that tend to spread the virus what we
farm is that infected on our trips
preferred unanimously from the get-go in
the timecodes experiment they preferred
uninfected leaf or a healthy block and
uninfected soybean trips initially seem
to have preferred the infected plant but
then they change and switch over their
preference to an uninfected blood and
what this means the fact that infected
soybean trips prefer healthy plant this
means there is a high potential for a
virus printer that these infected insist
in sex will seek out preferentially
these healthy plants and transmit the
virus and potentially layer over posit
fear eggs there and then the first
instar will emerge they open they'll get
infected by feeding on this infected
material and spread the virus so the
potential for virus spread is is huge
with the outcome that we saw in this
system
now I mentioned about the 8 different
species that we found in Indiana we were
interested in the top 3 species because
these species of Correspondence 50% of
the soybean clips populations in in a
soybean field I'm sorry it's deformed
50% of the clips population in soybean
fields and the three top species were
soybean clips these sunflower traps and
tobacco trips and you can see the
pictures here this one's Eastern el soy
bean threads the blackish one is tobacco
and the yellowish looking one is Eastern
flower so we were interested to know if
these three species would be poor would
be potential vectors especially tobacco
tips which is known to transmit other
Cosco viruses now Eastern flower trips
is interesting it's never been known to
be a vector believer interested in it
because it was the most predominant
species in our trips captures and we
wanted to see if they kept shots with a
spell so we twisted 4's VNV presence in
the insect itself and this is a rt-pcr
gel showing the presence of SP n v NS s
which is a non structural protein and
pecan in the insect and we did in fact
detected in all three species a lot more
I should say intensity or concentration
of the virus in the soybean villages st
tobacco trips but we do see a
significant presence in eastern flower
church itself this was a very
interesting and finding for us which you
know necessitated that we look at it
further
so we then attested if these insects
could transmit the virus then to and
healthy plants to be performed hot lot
assays and what we found was that n
variables which is
soy bean trips had the highest level of
virus infection or are able to transmit
the virus most effectively up to 70
percent followed by tobacco trips which
was due to around 35 36 percent and
finally Eastern flower trips franklinia
triticeae they were able to do to 7% but
still you know given that they I said
that they were they formed the largest
proportion in our insect captures from
soybean fields it's possible that you
know with these high numbers they could
overcome the low transmission rate so we
will just know why these different trips
species have these different
transmission rates and to understand a
little more the dynamics within the
insect to do that we performed confocal
microscopy experiments and explain this
a little briefly to you
so essentially first and stars were of
not just soy bean touch this is just a
picture of one species of the three
different species were given access was
because acquisition access period of 24
hours on virus affected tissue and ice
will be impacted tissue and then they
were allowed to their loved to adulthood
on clean tissue then 24 hours post
occlusion the adults were dissected and
their guts and salivary glands were
labeled vocal microscopy so you can see
parts this is after the dissection the
guts are being excised out the entire
elementary c'mon actually this picture
shows it a little better you can see all
of the structures so you have your four
got here there here's two lobes of the
principal salivary glands you can see
mid-cut one the main site of infection
midgut 2 and also may get three and then
you have these two tubular structures
the tubular celebre glands that connect
the mid gut to the principal salivary
glands
so this is looking at immuno labeling
experiments in soybean trips after a
spammy infection after six hours of
acquisition access period on virus
infected plant the first panel here from
eight to D isn't healthy on an
uninfected insect that was exposed to
healthy plant tissue and you don't see
any virus while assist it was labeled
with his little green and the way we did
it was by using this first and I FITC
just conjugated to an antibody against
the primary antibody which targets s VNV
but in the infected tissue you can see
the the fluorescence is very obvious
here you can see it in the form gut
which is denoted by the yellow arrows
here in the mid cut you can see some
light ones in the tubular salivary gland
and not so much in the principal
salivary glands so this is after six
hours of ATP I should also mention that
the blue are the the darkest evening for
the nuclei and the red is active so this
is looking at immuno detection in
soybean Crips after 12 and 24 hours the
first panel on top is 12 hours and eat
through I is 24 hours and you can see
very clearly in comparison to the
previous images these images are green
fluorescing with the the virus so you
can see it in the makeup here in the
four
in the tubular salable hands and
principal celebrant just after 12 hours
and the same case here
after 24 hours so this confirms this was
already known but nobody had performed
the confocal microscopy experimental
actually look at the protein in the
insect for this confirms and the
presence of that soybean tips are the
vector this is looking at as we Envy
after 24 hours a a P we didn't do the
time course with the Eastern flower
which is EF Tian and tobacco tips the
top panel is first garbages tobacco
turrets and the bottom panel is Eastern
flowers drips and again you can clearly
see virus infection in the sky in the
mid cut the tubular salivary gland and
the principal sound of the glands very
clearly and same with the Eastern flower
too it's very clearly seen in the
principal salivary glands and I am the
detection of the virus in the principal
salivary gland is important because if
it's present in the principal Sullivan
glands and the virus will definitely
come out into the lumen and then through
the saliva it's not just present the
presence in any other structure may not
indicate or may not correlate with virus
transmission as much as present in the
principal salivate landis and you can
see it in the mid cut as well so to
conclude this talk there's a lot of
information that we are starting to
accumulate about my respect to the
interactions but there is need to
understand specific genes and proteins
which will help us in identifying
technologies or strategies that can help
you limit the transmission of plant
pathogens we're a long way from there
because it's a challenging system that
as I mentioned our spoons are small but
still there have been there has been a
lot of progress specially with the
tomatoes
built virus and Westerplatte rip system
and understanding the genes and proteins
that are involved in virus transmission
and with that I'd like to thank my
funding sources including present and
past funding and I've called my my team
here at IPFW my graduate students and
undergraduate students some of whom are
in this picture here past collaborators
and current collaborators and I'd end my
talk and take questions at this time
thank you thank you dr. Nakata for that
informative presentation
it's time for QA it's a help if you have
a question you'd like to ask please do
so now just click on the green Q&A
button at the lower left of the
presentation window type your question
into the box that appears on your screen
then click on the send button will
answer as many of your questions as we
have time for if we are unable to get to
your question we will follow up with you
via email after the presentation let's
get started our first question is does
sleeping vein necrosis virus cause yield
loss in soybean really identified there
is not much known about it let me go
back and answer this again just to be
sure that everybody heard it for the
longest time we had no idea if it did
cause he lost those anecdotal evidence
that it caused he lost to up to 46% but
a paper was recently published which
actually shows that soybean vein
necrosis does not reduce year however
oil content and fatty acid content are
decreased which means that it would
affect the quality of the seed and not
so much the quantity but that would
still a
in fact you know productivity for or for
the growers thank you for that answer
the next question is why are some trips
species able to transmit virus better
than others fully loaded question I
don't think we know that is a fully
loaded question I don't think we
understand all the factors because there
could be so many factors including
genetic and environmental factors right
so as I said the virus has to move
through these different organs as it
makes its way up to the Sun of the
glands so there could be different
barriers to transmission it means to
escape the midcard epithelium escape and
then you know escape the salivary gland
tissues in get into the lumen so there
could be challenges and blocks to
transmission during that mechanism
there's also insect immunity that can
kick in and as I showed in my SVN beat
presentation Wireless level starts to go
down after one thirdly just you know a
high point so the the immune response
kicks in which may cause trade offs
lipstick and et so there could be
several mechanisms and then
environmental temperature and humidity
can also affect transmission also the
host plant so there are several factors
that need to come together but in if you
just think about the insect we know that
the virus interacts with the specific
you know cutie two receptor than the
inside carton and they could be
expression in these receptors that might
differ between the different species
on one species maybe having a totally
different type of receptor so again that
would go back to the genetics that will
Bailey between these different species
thank you we'll wrap up with one more
question then that question is how can
the knowledge of genes and proteins help
in developing disease control strategies
so that's a great question so
understanding it both in the plant and
the insect vector is important or the
insect is important because that way you
could develop transgenic technologies
you could either knock down the genes or
over it if there's a gene but for
instance in the insect one that is the
putative receptor could be knocked down
or silenced and then which would not
allow the virus to bind to the insect in
the plants you could think of potential
genes that could be over expressed like
defense gene and that could protect the
plant against this pathogen or you could
make transgenic plants that have
proteins that might block these putative
receptor in the insect and a similar
stir and a study on these lines was
published by my previous collaborators
who are now at North Carolina State
University so essentially by
understanding gene and proteins you
could develop transgenic technologies in
the insect and the plants that could
make them unable maintain SiC unable to
transmit the virus or make the plant
more resistant to the virus
great thank you and it does look like we
have one more question and that question
is can toast the viruses be transmitted
by seed or pollen recently until last
year until last year we had no idea that
possible viruses could be transmitted
via scene but interestingly SV NV was
was found to be transferring the seed
transmitted to a very small extent
actually only six percent but still it's
the first toss pro viruses that can be
transmitted by seed but notoya I don't
have any knowledge of ROM trust for Isis
that can be transmitted via pollen which
would have implications for the bee
population I would imagine but I don't I
don't believe they do
I would like to once again thank dr.
neta Ezer her presentation do you have
any final comments see everybody at lab
roots and I hope you enjoy I want to
thank everybody at lab roots for giving
me this opportunity and I hope the
audience find the presentation useful
thank you once again dr. Nakata I would
also like to thank lab roots for making
today's educational webcast possible
before we go I want to let everyone know
that today's webcast will be available
for on-demand viewing through December
14th
2017 you'll receive an email from lab
roots letting you know when this webcast
will be available to replay please share
that announcement with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
that's all for now thank you for joining
us we hope to see you again soon goodbye